[Music]
[Applause]
spent maybe a lot more time than I
thought I was going to on the Oakland
A's with what's going on the reverse
protest the commissioner then had a
couple of comments and um I just thought
they were uncalled for you're the
commissioner of baseball I don't think
you're supposed to have this kind of
attitude towards the Oakland A's where
they did try something yes it's too late
yes the A's are moving to Vegas but uh
here is the commissioner talking about
the reverse boycott from Oakland A's
fans
you know I mean it was great it's great
to see what is
this year you know almost an average
Major League Baseball crowd in the
facility for one night that's a great
thing okay
you don't need that
you know let's move on
Evan gettings uh works for 95 7 the game
in the Bay Area joins us on the program
recap the past week if you can for me
Evan
it hasn't been an easy one Dan and but
quite honestly it's been in lockstep
with what ownership the Oakland
Athletics and commissioner Major League
Baseball Rob Manfred have continued to
say and echoed on that that sound bite
right there it's it's been tough because
a lot of Oakland A's fans both in the
greater Bay Area along with around the
country a few that I know around the
world feel like they've been spit on
Kick dirt on and that last see on the
way out the door was something that I
think you put appropriately it was
uncalled for everyone knows that they're
leaving for Las Vegas everyone knows
that they've been trying to leave for
Las Vegas for quite some time and to
hear the commissioner Major League
Baseball essentially give you a sort of
kick in the rear on the way out
didn't exactly feel great but I'm trying
to understand this of what Oakland
offered or what baseball wanted from
Oakland and what Vegas offered and what
baseball wanted from Vegas are they
Apples to Apples
not exactly and that's why a lot of A's
fans feel like John Fisher Dave Campbell
and the rest of that ownership group in
Oakland uh just simply didn't want to be
there because the mayor of Oakland came
out yesterday discussed the essentially
demands the asks from the Oakland A's to
the city of Oakland which
kind of centered on a 15 billion dollar
project that included not just a
ballpark but housing uh infrastructure
renovations to the city of Oakland to
create a more bustling busy downtown
area across you know multiple Acres
across far more Acres that are what are
being asked for in Las Vegas now that is
only just a 1.5 billion dollar project
so what the Oakland A's asked for from
their own town was not something that
the city of Las Vegas was even in the
ballpark for no pun intended so that's
what people are trying to figure out and
really have an understanding of and are
wrestling with is that you feel
like they did not want to be here in the
first place and they have been trying
the entire time to essentially scapegoat
the Oakland A's fans into not being the
ones that supported into not being the
ones that showed up when in reality it
all comes down to any so what we all
knew that this was about Dan and that's
the color green
baseball charges a relocation fee which
was supposed to be 300 million dollars
the commissioner said that the league
would waive the A's relocation fee if
they moved to Las Vegas
I mean he was he was doing his best to
incentivize Vegas like please take them
uh and I'm going to give you an easy out
right yeah yeah that no that's that's
exactly correct and and that's just
another way in which people have felt
like they've been disrespected and like
you know the commissioner was never on
their side in the first place and like
this isn't exactly something that uh it
doesn't align with what Rob Manford has
been viewed as and has represented
himself as I mean this is the same guy
that called the World Series trophy a
piece of metal uh this was the same guy
that did a poor job in my opinion and
many others of reprimanding the Houston
Astros cheating scandal uh this has been
a guy that has been always down for the
bottom line which is how do I create
dollars for my owners and John Fisher is
an owner of a Major League baseball team
and so I'm sure at some point Rob
Manford was willing to to maybe you know
find a way to to try and incentivize the
city of Oakland but those asks were not
even in the same realm as what he was
going to give the A's to move to Las
Vegas like you may mentioned waving a
relocation fee something that wasn't
even on the table when we started this
entire process when did the A's move
and that's that's going to be the
question I mean there's been reports
about them potentially playing in Reno
while the stadium is being built I know
from having been at the reverse boycott
on Tuesday night at the Oakland Coliseum
that there's a lot of people that will
never step foot in the Coliseum again
that was their last A's game and that
was their last opportunity to you know
voice their frustrations to well to wear
sell t-shirts uh to chant certain
obscenities towards people that they're
frustrated with in the Oakland A's
office and that's the their last last to
rock then and it's it was sad to see as
someone that grew up going to that
Coliseum as someone that had envisioned
potentially taking their future family
to that Coliseum or around the city of
Oakland not being able to see A's logos
gear on children on elderly on families
uh is going to be something that's going
to make me sad because I know that even
if they are it's just simply going to be
a relic of something that was lost if I
put this to a fan vote do you want the
Oakland A's to take the nickname A's or
do you want them to leave it
I personally think they should Rebrand
and look if there's a possibility for a
future major league baseball team an
expansion team that comes to Oakland in
the future the city would be more than
welcome to open its arms up and maybe
rename them the A's uh but I I have to
imagine you know when the Cleveland
Browns left Cleveland the first time I
don't think they wanted a Baltimore of
them to be called the Browns nor do I
think that ownership group wanted them
to be uh it's it's just simply too
difficult I think for a lot of people to
see and also quite frankly the city of
Las Vegas should not want them to be
called the A's because of how John
Fisher and the A's have handled this
entire process they have not been
exactly great businessmen throughout
this entire Saga of trying to move them
to Las Vegas or stay in Oakland whatever
they purport so if I'm a team in Las
Vegas I'm a fan of a Las Vegas baseball
team I don't want any part to do with
the A's because everything you associate
it with right now has to do with greed
gluttony and things that aren't simply
going to make your baseball team and
franchise that attractive
Evan thanks for joining us we appreciate
your time absolutely Dan thank you so
much it's Evan Giddings 95 7 the game
and a good local reaction there I'm just
curious about that